I certainly think the government needs
to regulate the use made of genetic
information because if it doesn't we're
going to get into a situation where rich
people can buy information that enables
them to select certain among a variety
of embryos select the best children of
the children of the most talents and
poor people are not and I think that's
going to produce a society that's even
more sharply divided along lines of rich
and poor than our society is today and I
don't think we want or should one such a
society so on the genetics matter I do
think there's a need for regulation on
the use of stem cells for research the
only regulation that I would see would
be if any one we're going to use them
for Reproductive purposes but I don't
think that that's very likely I don't
know anyone who's focusing on that
so if stem cells or embryos are to be
used to remove stem cells and the stem
cells are then going to be used for
research and destroyed are not allowed
to develop into an embryo and then a
fetus and a child I really don't see
much need to regulate that
my defense of abortion is is unique
because it does not try to draw a sharp
distinction between the fetus and the
infant it acknowledges the point that
opponents of abortion make that there is
simply a gradual development of the
human being that continues during the
first months of life after birth as well
as beforehand so I think the question
about abortion we should ask is not is
the embryo or fetus a living human being
because I think the answer is
undoubtedly yes it is the the question
is what characteristics or capacities
does of being have to have in order to
make the case that that being has a
serious right to life and when we ask
that question I think it's not hard to
see that the answer when it's a member
of the species Homo Sapien is not really
a very persuasive answer why should
membership of one particular species be
determinative of whether you have a
right to life or not so if we reject
that answer then we're going to have to
look at the characteristics of the
beings and say are these characteristics
such that if you have them you have a
right to life and if if you don't you
don't and I think we can explore what
those characteristics might be but the
most important point is to break away
from the idea that its membership of our
species in itself that really is the
morally crucial marking line dividing
you